this guy's throwing some beautiful
rhetoric rad chew some science someday
and then how does the story go I belong
on where he says that the certain amount
of Xena is written for every human being
the Xena and without exception every one
of them was deeply involved in
pornography what a day when you see some
people who are going down that route do
you ever call them out directly I say
the most important thing that your
children need to be doing is practicing
as long as they're saying on one end
this will you'll have a faith crisis but
then they're saying watch more well why
didn't you just say oh well you can just
go masturbate you know just go do that
and you'll be okay
salamualikum' greed is a piece welcome
to the Dean show we have another
exciting show every week we're here at
hamdulillah we got ISA Imam ISA wood in
the studio how are you
what a comes Salam around doing good
even though it's freezing cold here in
Chicago we don't have this kind of
weather in North Carolina no not this
kind of cold now sometimes maybe at
night during the winter but yeah this is
this is frigid how have you been good
man up hamdulillah since the last time I
saw you
Allah blessed me with two children
masha'Allah congratulation thank you so
it's interesting you were telling me how
this all came about this topic now that
you really went down this rabbit hole
right usual you watch the topic that we
did on we had a guest on the show it was
actually a Christian and somehow the
topic of pornography came up yes and
then what happened from there well I
think that you you turned me on to to a
channel that you it you had interviewed
someone own and then when I went to the
channel to watch the gentleman he posted
something that really piqued my interest
he he said he showed an article from
Psychology Today which is kind of a
famous online periodical article and
it's mentioned that the heading of the
article was watch more porn and in the
article it basically stated that
pornography use led to faith crises and
you know I've never heard anything like
that before you know obviously as a
Muslim I know watching pornography is
haram it's wrong you shouldn't do it
it's but I didn't know that it would
cause a person to start to doubt their
faith so it calls me to actually go look
up the original article and then I
started reading article after article
after article on Psychology Today about
pornography and pornographic use and
then and you know I think a lot spent on
data for this because you know sometimes
he just inspires you to remember
something from the tradition that helps
you make the connection and I remembered
that you know the the prophet mohammed
salah salem said that lie has needs an e
Haena yes nila who a movement that when
a person commits zina that there are not
a believer and that's not the only way
you can translate that you can translate
it is
when a person commits zina they lose
faith time they're doing it right and
this is the traditional explanation of
the Harlem of the scholars what else is
in the hadith talks about stealing when
a protest will lead to it and of course
consuming intoxicant they'll all have
the same effect and the reason for that
effect is actually quite interesting
what what's happening psychologically
inside of you whenever you commit
certain types of major sin is this what
is a man anyway a man is as the Prophet
Muhammad slaves long to find it the
belief in in in God Allah his angels his
books the messengers the day of judgment
and the decree the good and the bad of
it but these are all aspects of the
unseen you don't see these things with
these eyes you see them with the
internal sight like when you pray you
sense God but it's not a one of your
five senses it's an internal light that
you have on well when you go and commit
zina and when you say zina we're talking
about adultery and fornication sex
outside of marriage you you have to
temporarily suspend that belief in your
mind you have to kind of push the idea
that that God Allah is watching you and
that the Angels are recording your deeds
and that you're responsible for that on
the day of judgment and you temporarily
suspend that belief long enough to
commit that sin once the sin is over if
you were a believer when you did it then
then Amen the light will come back and
own inside of you and you'll feel regret
and that's the natural inclination we
all have to repent for the sin to make
Toba as we call it or teshuva and Hebrew
and this is part of the Abrahamic
tradition so after a while when you do
it long enough it creates a
contradiction inside of your your your
conscious mind and what happens is that
your you you have this internal
dissonance that goes on where you're
telling yourself that you're religious
and that that your religion tells you
not to do this and it's wrong but you're
doing it anyway and so your your your
internal consciousness will fight until
you you you tip one way or the other and
that's actually what these psychologists
have discovered also that porn
pornography used does this now
pornography isn't Xena of the private
parts you know you're not going and
getting another person and committing as
an act of sex with them but the profit
didn't limit Xena to that there's
another hadith from the same narrator
Abihu right all the along on where he
says that the certain amount of Xena is
written for every human being the Xena
of the eye which is to lustfully stare
at things the Xena of the ear which is
to listen to sexually explicit language
the Xena of the tongue which is to say
sexually explicit things the Xena of the
hand which is to touch something in a
sexually explicit way and then finally
the Xena of the feet which is to go to
the places where Xena are committed well
pornography is at least three of those
the Xena of those three huh yeah the
Xena of the eye the ear and the hand
because those are the things involved in
it and eventually is gonna lead you most
likely to before thorne eventually it's
going to lead you to the next step to
committing the actual act yeah yeah I
mean it will do that but even if it
didn't it's still the Xena that will
cause faith to leave you yeah and
subhanAllah when I did the research on
pornography use in the world today it is
so ubiquitous
I mean it's 90% of American people are
watching that's not that's the is that
now the number one addiction is porn
well I mean I can't say that it's the
number one addiction because even
psychologists don't officially come out
and say that it's an addiction even
though we have sexaholics Anonymous just
like we have Narcotics Anonymous and
alcoholics Anonymous and I personally
know people who have been and are
addicted to pornography and they'll
admit it but what's interesting and even
they point this out in their papers is
that people who are less religious like
atheists agnostics and the so-called nun
category non-affiliated they don't tend
to see a problem with their pornography
use its religious people who do
Buddhists Hindus Christians Muslims are
the types of people that when they use
pornography they feel bad about it and
they they feel regret after they've done
it yeah and so that's what they're
pointing out in these articles is that
it leads to a crises in your faith yeah
I want to get your reaction to this so
this led you watching this program that
we did with the Christian is
Benjamin Owen Benjamin and he touched
upon this and then you went down and you
actually develop a program now where
you're actually going to different
massage it in different places
communities and and what are you doing
exactly so what I realize is this if you
look from 2007 to 2014 a poll was done
that showed that there was an increase
in a particular religious category in
this country called nuns which I just
mentioned or atheists agnostics and non
affiliate not affiliated means like you
grew up in a Muslim family or a
Christian family or Jewish family but
you don't associate anymore this
category drew grew by almost 20 million
members in that period from 2007 to 2014
and everywhere I go in the country I've
been Tom you know over a hundred maybe
close to 200 Muslim communities in the
past six years I see the same problem in
all of them the youth are either checked
out internally they don't practice but
they don't say that they're not Muslim
or they've literally left the religion
and I this is like a modern phenomenon
so when I discovered this thing about
pornography and how ubiquitous the use
of it was I realized hold on a second
it's affecting our community it's
affecting the Christian community the
Jewish community and it's the reason I
believe that so many people are losing
faith today and so I developed a program
where I come into Muslim communities and
I teach about this epidemic problem of
pornography use and especially amongst
your even religious people they say even
that close as high as 50% of pastors in
the Christian Church admit to having
pornography issues you know I mean it's
it's affecting our community for sure so
you're seeing a direct correlation with
people with particularly people of all
these face but now when you go to the
Muslim communities that Muslims who are
engaged in this type of activity that
it's a definitely a cause of them
potentially leaving the Dean or having a
crisis in the Dean I'll tell you I know
personal stories
Ettie of people who were serious
practicing Muslims I mean praying five
times a day at the Masjid fasting on
Mondays and Thursdays like sitting in
classes and they got on that porn in and
they're gone
they don't practice anymore yeah and I
and I know it was the porn because are
these particular people admitted to
having
problems with it before yeah and I
recognized that like for example in one
of their cases it was somebody who who
didn't have access to the Internet and
they were really serious practicing
Muslim and then all of a sudden they got
a brand new laptop and man they
disappeared and and I know people who
admitted to me of having what's the age
range here usually though your and your
your experience this is the saddest part
of all I mean we have people emailing I
mean I know one of my teachers admitted
to having an 11 year old email him about
pornography use I mean this is the
average age people are exposed to it you
have a 1 in 17 chance every time you log
on the Internet of accidentally seeing
pornography even you're 6 years old and
so by 14 some of the studies say 94% of
children have seen it and it's nice I
mean we have to be clear it's totally
natural for human beings once they reach
puberty to want to see the bodies of
other human beings it mean this is
something a lot of put in all of us the
attraction right but this attraction is
now being co-opted by the pornography
industry and and and you know it's it's
such an easy addiction to fall into
because it's it's a private matter you
know you're doing it alone by yourself
with your now smartphone used to be
laptops and DVDs and visa you know VHS
cassettes back in the day but but now
it's like anyone can access at anytime
on their phone and you're doing it alone
and and no one is talking about mean
it's it's a political issue that no one
even cares about do you think we're
talking about it enough the community no
and that's why I teach this this this
class you know because this is a I mean
it's just common sense I mean what
you're saying I like the way you made
the connection here is that and let's
touch upon that again you mentioned
because psychologists this psychologists
they're admitting that this is will
destroy your faith and then you're
saying just get rid of the faith get rid
of your religion get rid of pretty much
Islam so you don't have that guilt guilt
yeah let's let's go to cuz you a good
thing to do is usually to look at the
end result you practice Islam you live
it you live a good wholesome life and at
the end you get Jenna okay that's one
scenario here another scenario you get
into alcohol you get into fornication
keep going
and at the end we see destruction just
look at the celebrities and all the
other rock stars who indulge in a
lifestyle you actually part of the
lifestyle too rock band man
yeah I've seen celebrity to destroy
themselves okay front of my own face you
know so we're making a parallel you
indulge in certain activities just take
it to the extreme if you keep going down
this road this will is what will happen
let's give another extreme you heard a
10 Ted Bundy yes
all right I want you to watch this and
then let's see thing I know the video
you're about let's play many people have
but this tell us you know a little bit
about Dan Bunny Ted Bundy he was uh he
was convicted and then he was executed
for raping and murdering everything
around third from what they found out
about 30 women mm-hmm right let's see
what he has to say
[Music]
so this is a day before he got executed
as it as a young a young boy and I mean
the boy 1213 certainly that I
encountered outside the home again in
the local grocery store or the local
drugstore the softcore pornography what
people call softcore and it happens it
happened in stages
gradually it doesn't necessarily not to
me at least happen overnight
once you become addicted to it and I
look at this as a kind of addiction like
other kinds of addiction of addiction
you keep I would keep looking for more
potent more explicit most reckless signs
of material like an addiction you keep
craving something which is harder harder
something which which gives you a
greater sense of excitement again I'm
talking from personal experience hard
real personal experience most damaging
kinds of pornography are those that
involve violence and sexual violence
some people would would say that well I
I've seen that stuff and it doesn't do
anything to me I wasn't a pervert in the
sense that you know people look at
somebody and say I know there's
something wrong with him and just tell I
mean I I was essentially a normal person
I had good friends i i i live in normal
life except for this one small but very
potent and very destructive segment of
it that i kept very secret and very
close to myself and didn't let anybody
know about it i'm no social scientist
and I haven't done a survey I mean I
don't pretend that I know what John Q
citizen thinks about this but I've lived
in prison for a long time now and I've
met a lot of men who were motivated to
commit violence just like me
and without exception every one of them
was deeply involved in pornography
without question without exception
deeply influenced and consumed by an
addiction
or not there's no question about it the
FBI's own study on serial homicide shows
that the most common interest among
serial killers mister namitha
and pornography can reach out and snatch
a kid out of any house today PA snatched
me out of my own it snatched me out of
my home 20 30 years ago and as diligent
as my parents were and they were
diligent and protecting their children
and as good a Christian home as we had
and we had a wonderful Christian home
there is no protection against the kind
that the kinds of influences that are
loose and a society that tolerates their
kids sitting out there switching the TV
dial around and come upon these movies
late at night or I don't know one
they're wrong but they're on and the kid
can watch them it's scary when I think
what would have happened to me if I had
seen I was scary enough I mean that I
just ran into stuff outside the home but
it's big to to know the children are
watching that kind of thing today or can
pick up their phone and dial away for it
or send away for it and that's coming to
the present now because what I'm talking
about happened 30 20 30 years ago that
is in my formative stages and what
scares and appalls me dr. Dobson is when
I see what's on cable TV some of the
movies I mean some of the violence in
the movies thought they come into homes
today with stuff that they that they
wouldn't show in an x-rated adult
theaters 30 years ago so now you already
heard of Ted Bundy he was a serial
killer I've seen that video too before
you've seen that video but he's on his
last day they're executing on him the
next day I believe and now he's letting
the world know come coming out I mean
was what I mean
whatever good is left in him he's
letting the world know that hey this is
my dark secret this was he grew up in a
Christian home went to church he seemed
like he was just a normal kid
and what he's attributing it to is to
the porn
well explicitly this violent porn well I
mean the first thing that comes to mind
when I see that video is you know Allah
says in the Quran you know yeah you had
ladina Amman ooh oh you who have Amman
faith lat
tell you who taught his shape on like do
not follow the incremental steps of the
devil
what may yet to bear who taught is
Shaitaan in the who yeah Moodle bill
fasciae you in one car if you follow
those steps he will command you to do
disgusting and immoral things so this is
God Almighty saying in the verbatim with
God the quran yet saying don't follow
even the footsteps and and he met he
admits that like you know he started off
with what he considers like softcore
porn like you know magazines that just
have naked pictures of people but then
he moved on to the films and everything
else and pornography today is so
unbelievably disgusting I mean the
articles that you can read online about
what goes on in these films will make
you sick to your stomach and this is the
most mainstream stuff we're talking
about like gang rape porn torture porn
yeah there was there's a there's a
there's a post yeah it says that number
for most watched video this week with
over 4 million views is of a teen girl
where her hands feet shackled down mouth
gagged being penetrated with the Machine
electrocuted and she until she is
screaming in pain and her body burnt
with wax it says don't tell me
porns not violence against women yeah I
mean it's absolutely horrific and I mean
and this this is the mainstream stuff
it's it's that's where the feminists in
all this well you know they hold
movement the women's movement the one as
if a woman's right this is like an
oppression of tour of women nowadays
yeah it's it's absolutely horrific and
and Chris Hedges who's actually a friend
of the Muslim community you know he was
a war correspondent during the Gulf War
and he suffers from PTSD he actually
went and interviewed these porn stars
and he he said the first thing he
noticed as he interviewed them is that
they all had PTSD just like him
post-traumatic stress disorder which you
developed from being in a war zone and
then they admitted to him that before
they went on the set to perform these
acts on cam
that they were taking fistfuls of
oxycontin so that they were so
physically and mentally numb that they
could go and perform these painful
disgusting and demeaning acts these
these horses particularly probably the
women huh yes the women he's
interviewing and he mentions that by the
time they're finished their bodies are
black and blue that they're going in for
surgeries to repair their body I mean
this is horrific and this is the
mainstream pornography people are
watching you're 11 12 13 year-old boys
and girls are watching this I mean can
you imagine what that is doing to their
minds I mean it's turning it's it's just
it causes them to just see people as
just objects of their desire to be used
and abused and and one one Muslim sister
asked me at a youth conference I didn't
and she said how do I know if my husband
is doing this and I say is he asking you
to do things that are painful disgusting
and demeaning and that's I'm telling you
that's where he's getting these ideas
from because normal interaction between
men and women is not supposed to be
painful it's not supposed to make you
feel humiliated it's not supposed to to
be like that supposed to be a loving
experience but that's not what porn
teaches porn teaches us to use and abuse
people and you know I mean clearly the
Ted Bundy was a lunatic and I mean we
have to factor that in but it's
interesting that he would even bring
that up on his last days you know that
that was a contributing factor to his
interest in that type of behavior so
it's certainly a part of his his illness
or the development of it and not just
that he said that from all his time that
he spent he spent a lot of time in
prison before he was executed then he
also he made the example of all the
other the majority of how many inmates
and there were in there for violent
crimes they also had this addiction well
I have a friend in an Atlanta hue ESCO
and he actually does a program for the
Muslim community also in pornography and
he admitted that in the violence against
women classes that one of the things
they would tell you as a husband is that
if you're going to continue to stay in
this marriage you have to stop watching
pornography now that's a very
interesting this is one class
it's classes that men take who were
involved in violence against women the
classes that they have to take and he
said that one of the things
they tell you in those classes is that
you're not allowed to watch pornography
as part of your recovery process because
they know they know what pornography
does to men they know that it teaches
them to it to use and abused women and
and and the same thing is doing to women
also that watch it because there are
women who watch a large portion of women
are watching it these days and you know
what what I found so fascinating is that
if you look at that category of people
who make up the the so-called nuns that
non-affiliated atheist agnostic their
increase takes place at a particular
time in history and amongst men
specifically in the millennial
generation the very generation that had
internet access to it for the first time
in history so in 1994 the first websites
come into people's homes and by 2010 75%
of access to this industry is now on
smartphones so this entire generations
millennial generation has been raised on
this stuff and and just having access to
it all the time and so my general theory
was this is that when the Prophet said
peace be upon him that a man would leave
you when you commit zina
the Shaitaan figured out a way for you
to commit zina all the time without even
needing another person and and that's
what it's done is it keeps putting the
light out inside of people Christians
Jews Muslims alike and they're leaving
religion because they they they're
choosing to side with the sin over the
repentance I want to go back to that
where you in your personal case study
and then I'm sure many Imams and others
if they look into this though they're
going to probably see a lot of
similarities here now you have to make a
decision because you have you mentioned
that even the psychologists are telling
you that this will destroy your
religiosity your Eman this will cause a
faith crisis now their solution is to
get rid of the guilt all right so the
guilt is there the conscience is there
that Allah the creator of the heavens
never put that there that's like a check
engine light that's like slow down to
stockily they want to now get rid of
that so what are they saying they're
saying watch more porn
so they're saying watch more porn yeah
they want you to destroy that light
inside so now if you're now sadly many
Muslims you know people who are gauged
in this whoever they end up worshipping
in a sense you know the modern
psychologist psychiatrist they end up
just you know they have been with the
professors at the school they really
idolize people like this and they're
like hold on you know they can't be
wrong here so now you don't I don't have
a solid stance on your Dean you're not
well grounded and now this guy's
throwing some beautiful rhetoric grad
shoe some science someday and then how
does the story go well I mean it's it's
there you have to understand that all of
these people a lot most of your
professors in school even in the Islamic
Studies programs and in in even in these
psychology they're coming at these this
information from an atheist world
perspective this is very very crucial to
know this is very important and
understand and and so they've already
removed God and the angels and the books
and the messengers and the day of
judgment from the picture all together
so they're looking at it and they're
saying oh you know the problem isn't the
pornography the problem is your religion
you need to just get rid of the religion
and then you won't have any guilt and
but that guilt is in there for a reason
that's a gift from God to wake you up
and tell you like this is wrong what I'm
doing to myself because it you know and
just from just from an atheist
perspective it's a well-known fact that
pornography will lead to erectile
dysfunction it will lead to you not
being able to have a proper relationship
with another person you know I mean so
it has physiological impacts on you even
if you're not so how can these people
these psychologists particularly the one
that was writing about this they're
saying on one end this will you'll have
a faith crisis but then they're saying
watch more right but then we're you're
discussing that all these health
disasters and Mary's is that all this
stuff it will lead to that
right yeah and and and that's that's the
if we see it leading to them yeah and
and and this is Imams will admit that
they get tons of people who come into
their offices where it's it's found out
that they're having marital problems and
it's the man watching pornography or in
some cases the women watching
pornography and the same thing happens
in the Christian Church and Jewish
synagogue it's happening all over the
words affecting it's it's being used as
a weapon on demand so then this is like
their Dawa pretty much the shaytanic
Dawa through these people who don't know
any better because they don't have Deen
they don't have God in their life
so now they end up just recruiting more
for this for more people to go away from
right God and
and more towards atheism well you know I
mean and this is just something to be
aware of you know there are government's
who have used pornography as a weapon on
populations you know in 2002 the Israeli
Defense Force invaded the Palestinian
Authority television stations and they
took over three or four of them and for
an entire weekend in Ramallah all you
could see is pornographic films 24 hours
a day seven days a week this is doctor
this is when and now this should really
raise a serious question for everybody
why would a government a government who
collects tax money from its citizens and
would risk the lives of its military
professionals to break into a television
station to play pornography for their
enemy if they didn't know that it would
do something to them you know they know
that pornography is a destructive force
that it breaks up families that it
causes faith crises in people that it
causes anger inside of people and that
it divides society and makes you weak
you know and so they use it as a weapon
and I believe I mean that was back in
2002 I believe pornography is being used
as a weapon on all of humanity today I
mean I and I blamed the Internet service
providers because they're the very
people of access to shutting this stuff
down you know and we as believers have
to be smart we have to say to ourselves
you know I'm not gonna engage with this
content because it's only a weapon if
you allow it into your life
but for young people it's especially
difficult because they don't yet have
control over their wills like adults do
and there are tools inside of our
religion to help you develop your will
and so I I have a you know a 7-point
program to getting off of pornography or
from staying away from it you know the
first step begins with Toba you have to
acknowledge this is wrong if you've been
doing it and you have to ask Allah to
forgive you then you have to start
actually performing your prayers on time
if I have to say the number one thing I
see in a lot of people who have left
Islam is that they stop praying and
that's exactly what pornography does to
you puts you in a state of janaba and
then you have to go take a little so you
can pray well that's what the Shaitaan
wants you to do you want you to be in
janaba all the time so you eventually
just don't pray you miss prayers and so
you have to start praying on time but
then
you have to start doing things like
voluntary fasting because the Prophet
recommended voluntary fasting for people
who weren't married yet and this is one
of the most important tools because this
is one of the one things in the Quran
Allah clearly explains to you why he
prescribed this yeah you hella Dina
Amano Kuti bedico museum cam akuti
bottle adenine public Amla alikum Tata
[ __ ] that fasting is a tool that God has
given you to increase your consciousness
of him and so whenever you fast it's the
it's one of the types of a bada that
really it it turns that light of Allah
and the angels and everything on inside
of you in a very powerful way then you
have to be a person of dhikr you know
Allah says in the Quran that that one of
the Shetlands plans for you is Yasuda
home and victory la la Isla de that he
wants you to abandon remembering him
remembering God and abandoning your
prayer so you have to be a person who
you know in the morning in the evening
you say all the Oh rod that the things
that the Prophet recommended the last
three chapters of the Quran the
different protective dua they know
supplications that you say you have to
be a person who does this and you have
to be a person who's around good people
you know you have to that the the the
Quran tells us all the time to be part
of a Jamaa but be a part of a group of
believers be around a Sladek own you
know people who are righteous because
they're not gonna be people who are
gonna try and get you to do this stuff a
lot of pornography spreads because a
friend shows a friend or someone you
know wants you to go to a website and
look at something and so this this
process of Toba and praying and fasting
and making victor and being around good
people you know this protects a person
from going back to that type of behavior
you know and and and we have to be
people also that avoid being alone you
know our religion tells us to be people
who stay busy doing good you know all
the time you don't need to be alone in
your room with your cell phone you know
you need to be out doing something
keeping yourself busy you know and
lastly you know my advice especially to
the Muslim community these days is we
have to start facilitating marriage for
our young people you know we have a very
big problem in our community these days
of well
you know such-and-such it's gotta get a
four-year degree and then a master's in
a PhD and they got to get a house in the
car and once they're 32 you know then
they can get a wife and this is
unrealistic in this modern world and we
have people walking around today dressed
worse than prostitutes used to dress in
the 1950's and and and we want our
children from the moment they hit
puberty at 13 and 14 and then we want to
send them off to you know the the these
lice inchess environments and not expect
them to fall into sin you know it's just
not realistic we need to start
facilitating marriage for our young
people as soon as possible helping them
get married you know helping them get
apartments and I know people right now
in college cuz a lot of parents asked me
this question they they're married they
have children they're working and they
go to school and they just can't believe
that those things can all work together
but Allah puts blessings in marriage he
puts blessings when people do the halal
thing the permissible thing and we need
to get out of this mentality that if I
if I marry my child young at you know 18
19 years old this is gonna destroy their
education or destroy their no I mean
this is ridiculous having a spouse
actually helps you in life and me and
you both are not because we're married
you know I mean I'm the greatest
blessings in my life came when I got
married many people have taken this you
have you have a lot of many
entrepreneurs they take they talk about
this that many people have taken some of
the top entrepreneurs who have made it
who haven't even had some of the top
degrees but they talked about many of
these degrees for people have become
like something divine let's descend
right in this particular degree from the
school and then you sacrifice in many
cases Lamas not nothing we putting the
secular education above the education of
the Dean and the priorities that a loss
want the law has told us to do first and
foremost all right we put this above
that and then we wonder why we have
catastrophes well I say this to them I
say you know what would you rather have
like your child like happily married
practicing Islam doing the right thing
without a college degree or would you
rather have your child absolutely and
utterly addicted to pornography on a
pathway to Jahannam
preying but with a college degree you
know I mean we really got to put things
in perspective for a second we're people
who look beyond the life of this world
and so we have to start planning our
lives and the lives of our children
around that the most important thing
that your children need to be doing is
practicing Islam I mean that's you know
or whatever your belief is that the
practice of it is so important you know
and for us as Muslims we believe this is
the correct way you know and and our
religion offers a methodology for
achieving a relationship with God
through ritual and and that stuff
protects you too protects you from
falling into traps yeah and then you
have these institutions that are that
are just sucking the Amman out of out of
the children right out of the young
adults out of the and and then you have
all these things that come as a result
well once you cut that light off inside
of you and that's what the the
pornography is doing it's cutting the
light off you can give it all the Quran
and prayer and everything you want
you're not gonna have any spiritual
experiences from it you're not gonna
that inner sight is out so then it's
easy for doubts to be sewn inside of you
if you ask the average ex Muslim ex
Christian like why they left the
religion you know a lot of them will
give you sometimes really silly reasons
now that's not to say that they all have
silly reasons but sometimes some of the
reasons that I've heard from young
people why they left Islam or why they
left this or that or reasons that for me
is a believer they just don't I mean
they're insignificant things like that
would not cause me to doubt the
existence of God or something like that
but what I recognize is that through
their pornography addiction or their
drug addiction or their digital theft
addiction right because that's stealing
like anything else dealing movies and
games and everything else on the
internet that they cut that light off
inside of themselves and so those doubts
actually took root and grew so you can
see because you've been a part of that
Allah the Almighty is giving you the
foresight you can see in people who have
kind of come from that background have
grew up and have faced many of the
challenges that are out there you when
you talk to someone your average person
maybe he talks to him and then this this
person who's having this doubt for
instance the facade the front that he
comes with the front he has to try to
come intellectually he'll try to repeat
some things that he's heard from a
professor
but when you start digging when you
start digging all right then you'll see
like really he just wants to or she
wants they just want to follow their
lusts passions but they want to justify
is that the the the rejection of the
things that would cause them to feel
guilt for what they're doing exactly so
they want to shut off this check engine
light they're conscious now and they can
do it and a law says that you know
better on on that blue beam they put a
seal over there and then why do you want
to shut that off because you want the
guilt to go away so you can do what keep
going down that path of self-destruction
so destruction right so then it doesn't
really come down to you know yeah you
can have doubts but Islam answers all
those doubts legitimate some little
[ __ ] legitimate doubts but really at
the end of the day this is one of those
things that you've seen is the following
the lusts and passions desires in the
porn and this is what you're seeing we
need to talk more about you're seeing
that this is destroying people's Iman
and many people are leaving the Deen
because of this addiction yeah I mean I
mean when you look at the numbers and
I'm just being honest it's it's so
staggering how many I mean it's
literally everybody you know almost it's
watching it it may not be that they are
watching it every day or even every
month but according to this to the the
studies that have been done it only
takes one viewing of pornography to
start to change the way people think and
and and and as one brother put it you
know our our mind is like a hard drive
you know you can't just delete these
files off and a lot tells us very
clearly in the corner especially to men
you know Zoe you know need NASA Hawaii
mean and aneisa that the number one
thing on your list of desires for men is
going to be the attraction to women and
so those images of these women in these
films is gonna stay on your hard drive
now with time and recovery and Vicker
and all the things I mentioned it'll
start to be put in a file and then that
file will be compressed and then you
won't have access to it as easily in
your in your mind anymore but it's it's
almost impossible to get those images
out of your mind
and so and that's what the shaped line
won't see he gives you the the devices
so that he can inject the malware in you
you know and then once that's in you
it's in you all the time and it's
putting you in that state of mind all
the time and your reproductive system is
just on all the time and that's not a
state that we won't
people to be in yeah and it has to be
has its place but if it's if this
industry it has to be like you're saying
this is they don't emit it some
psychologists but I mean this is
statistically it's the number one
addiction because look how much money
just as generating it's more than 100
billion dollars more than football
basketball all of these getting more
hits than Amazon and Twitter and Netflix
combined combined yet so the kind of
money that means you got to have the the
people who are paying for this out there
and and that's going to lead to that
addiction and people ask all the time
like why is it so easily accessible is
because they don't have to charge for it
they can just put ads up on the page
while you're watching it and then the
advertisers are they're really getting
all the revenue you know and and you
know that's what makes it so awful is
that it's so easily accessible to people
you know never in the history of mankind
have we had this fitna on our own our
own humanity where people are watching
other people commit zina
you know in just massive numbers and
this is having such a drastic effect and
I fear for the Muslim world right now
the Muslim world is not in the top
twenty countries it's mainly European
countries and Western countries so to
speak that they have the highest numbers
but but as as the Internet becomes more
and more accessible to people you know
and these smartphones and are in the
hands of everybody you know I fear for
the Muslim world if those Roma and those
places don't start speaking about this
and the dangers of it and what what it
does to people because you know that
like I said it's being used as a weapon
on religious people I believe and
inshallah this can be a catalyst where
we can get more people motivated that's
my hope that's my was my full intention
for coming here today
to start more more Imams more spiritual
leaders from every faith group can start
joining together this is one thing to
work together on to try to and by the
way this is something that Muslims can
work across religious boundaries you
know we we can unite with with the with
the true believing Christian and Jewish
and Buddhist and Muslim world alone at
least fighting this evil you know what I
mean I mean because this is this is
primarily not promoted by people from
amongst us I mean we have unfortunately
people from amongst us in the industry
and for
some of the most popular ones are even
from our community but you know those
people don't you know are definitely not
part of the religious group of us and
you know this is something that really
we can look past our differences to look
towards a greater good which is that we
should all as religious people even
non-muslims speak out against as evil it
is evil and and you know kind of the
last thing I'll end on is that the
Prophet warned us about this he said
that there would come a fitna on on all
of humanity like waves of the ocean and
he said that it would be displayed to
the hearts of people like a flat mat
line-by-line and the heart that that is
exposed to it would become gradually
more and more black and the one who
didn't expose themselves to it their
heart would remain white until a time
would come when there would only be a
fully blackened heart that could hold no
good and a white heart that was gonna
stay white until the end of time and
then that one that has the black heart
they would no longer be able to tell the
difference between right and wrong and
they would totally be filled with hawa
desires yeah and this is to me and feel
free to disagree a clear prophecy about
a time when something would be available
that it was flat and it would show you
tempting things that would cause your
heart to become gradually more and more
black until today we have morality
you know collapsing all over the world
traditional reality become morality that
comes from religion do you ever since
you have the sixth you have this
experience meaning you can come in from
the days of Julia where you can kind of
know what people's interests and even
now today when you see some people who
are going down that route do you ever
call them out directly and say when they
try to come up with so-called
intellectual arguments your address then
they go to something else you address
that that do you ever go that on and and
then they'll admit it
yes in fact I was just talking to
someone who would like you'd be like
come on I know what's up I know what you
want to do like you talk straight with
me let's let's stop you know with all
the smoke yeah yeah I mean III straight
out asked a young
man the other day who had left Islam and
he was talking about all this stuff and
I said how much pornography did you use
to watch you just came on out his camera
and asked him because I know now what's
going on and he just admitted he said I
was a huge pornography addict just the
other day I was listening to NPR on the
way to to give a khutba in Virginia and
they had a Mormon guy on and he was
discussing how he had gradually left the
Mormon Church which is traditionally
very conservative and they asked him
they said you know what was your major
problem with the Mormon Church and he
just came out before he even said it I
knew what he was about to say he said I
have a problem with their stance on
pornography which is another way of
saying I watch pornography and I don't
like the fact that my church says that I
shouldn't be doing it does any Church
say it's okay I don't know of any church
that says okay but we even have people
now today you know even amongst the
Muslim community who are trying to make
this hell out no way yes and and and
they're doing it in incremental steps
you know by trying to gradually one
after another to say that these things
you know are not explicitly forbidden in
the religion and we really you know we
have you come across those people yeah I
mean it starts off what I've seen is
them them coming on on shows and on
YouTube channels and saying for example
oh there's nothing wrong with
masturbation you know it's that you know
there's no it's not explicitly forbidden
in the religion but yet we know that the
Companions didn't do this
we know that the prophets didn't do this
I mean we know that was that if it was
something that we were supposed to do
they would have told us to do it we even
have one tradition where the companions
are out with with the Prophet in the end
and they're they're doing a campaign
with him and they don't have their wives
with him and they come they come to the
Prophet and they say Oh Messenger of God
should we castrate ourselves and then he
tells them no of course you shouldn't do
something like that well why didn't he
just say oh well you can just go
masturbate you know just go do that and
you'll be okay that was a perfect
opportunity for him to teach us that
that was something to do but he never
did
and so you know it starts off with that
and then just moves on and on and on and
we have to put a stop to this you know
anytime we we have scholars and stuff
trying to make these things that we we
just intrinsically know are not right
you know Allah says in the Quran from
Anita
Amanita la vara a daddy Casa de eco-home
without doing anyone who seeks away
outside of marriage to to to fulfill
their sexual desires that person is
transgressing the limits of Allah you
know and what's interesting about that
word Allah Doon is it is it's related to
aggressing against Allah is limits you
become a person filled with aggression
and so today you have so many people who
allowed the pornography into their
hearts they become angry just like Ted
Bundy was mentioning all these people in
prison filled with anger and rage
because it's really get it from you know
that the pornography causes you to start
hating God hate yourself hate
institutions you're a part of it just
fills people with rage and what do we
see today a world filled with rage and a
world filled with pornography addicts
and I'm just trying to make the
connections I could be wrong and I'll
admit that then people can feel free to
disagree with me but I'm seriously
seeing a connection between these things
I mean it's not you don't have to be
Sherlock Holmes well and you know I mean
people want all kinds of scientific
studies and stuff and I say you know
just go read these articles in
Psychology Today and you'll see you know
yeah you know we had an insider right
here this guy in his last on his dying
bed and he's talking about even FBI
reports Ted Bundy he's talking all these
different serial killers in the prisons
and they all I mean what else do you
expect I mean from such such an evil
porn act other than more evil right yeah
it does it definitely doesn't breed any
good in your life you're much better off
of getting married and having a family
and that's another reason why they won't
porn so prevalent is so people aren't
starting families people aren't getting
together and and doing the things that
are halau you know because those are the
things that will bring you real joy yeah
there's nothing wrong with sex there's
nothing wrong with with enjoying the
pleasures that Allah has put into this
world but there's a halal way to do that
and and that's the avenue you need to
focus your attention on you know it's
not all of the other ways because
there's lots of other ways but those
those ways lead to spiritual mental and
physical destruction and that's that
that's just reality you can accept it or
you can reject it but it doesn't change
the fact that that's how things are yeah
last point last thing I want to ask you
it's real scary now when you talk about
access what can we do for the children
we're having access to some of these
phones and Internet now what do you
advise the parents well and this is the
toughest one because you know my own
personal way of dealing with this is
probably very different than most people
I don't have television in my home I
don't have laptops open and and desktop
computers on where people you know no
one's gonna have a phone alone in their
room you know I mean I that kind of
stuff I feel like when you hand a child
iPad and a smartphone a laptop for them
to have alone in the room you're handing
them a loaded weapon to shoot their eman
in the head yeah you know and and and
and a lot of parents are not realizing
what they're doing but it's just you
know it's so easily accessible for them
so what are you doing a specific case
where the the the schools the even
Islamic schools they're making the kids
get the iPads because they're doing the
testing and much of the curriculum is on
through the internet through these why
so there's a few things you can do if
you can't get the devices out of their
hands and out of your life then you have
to make them only public devices you can
only have them in the home in public
rooms the living room and the screen has
to be facing where parents can see at
all times you can't have these things
alone and you and no one can have these
things alone in their rooms and and then
there's filters that can be installed on
these to filter out a lot of the content
but the most important thing is to teach
them early about this stuff I mean you
can teach even very young children in a
way and using language appropriate for
them that you know hey there's pictures
and videos that are out there of people
without their clothes on doing things
alone together that are that are not
that are evil and wrong and if you come
across these things and chances are they
will let's just be realistic you know
the the first thing you do is shut it
down and leave the room you know just
shut your laptop down cut your phone off
walk away and tell somebody with what
happened you know and if it's a friend
trying to get you to watch it or
something you know immediately just get
out of that situation if you can because
if you can just prevent yourself from
ever allowing it into your heart you
know what I mean like staring at it in
and and just and
having pleasure from it you know but the
the real thing you should do is be
disgusted by it you know the first time
you see it just immediately just say
that this is wrong you know and that's
how you prevent yourself from going down
that path but parents really need to be
I mean this these technologies are great
they give you lots of access to
information but they have so many
trapdoors today that really I mean I
don't recommend getting you know young
children and even preteens and teenagers
these smartphones you know but I know a
lot of people are gonna completely
disagree with me they're gonna say I'm
ludicrous I mean it was it was Steve
Jobs Ludacris when he actually didn't
allow his own children the inventor of
these gadgets he didn't allow his child
you can look this up to have an iPhone
right Steve Jobs yeah well I mean I
don't blame him he's the inventor so
he's prohibiting his kids and was he
crazy but he knew the danger that was
potentially could affect his children
right did you know about that no I
didn't actually
well I mean you know I mean there's a
lot of people that didn't know and
understand what I'm saying and and even
people have said you know like if I find
out my children are involved in this
stuff I'm just gonna cut the internet
off and I don't care how much I have to
suffer because they know once you get on
that stuff man it will ruin your life
you know and and that's that's the
reality of it it's it's either the
technology and and you you letting your
children alone with it to babysit them
which is what unfortunately we do to
them today it's a form of child abuse to
me but the this this technology is going
to destroy the hearts of your children
and eventually their Eman and that's
that's the worst thing ever I mean who
wants to be on the day of judgment
whether their children and headed to the
Hellfire Subhan Allah this is a great
reminder for all of us yeah you had
ladina Avenue who and physically come
now like oh you who have faith like save
your family from a fire you know we as
fathers especially are responsible for
what our children and our and our
spouses do Imam Esau would thank you
thank you very much if people want to
invite you to come out to talk about
this at the community at the Masjid how
can they reach you
well it's totally free you can either
email me at e e s a a
at fu r q aan o RG isa at fork on org
you can also reach me through the Al
Furqan Foundation website you can email
any of the email addresses on there and
say that you're interested in having my
my piece of woods program I don't charge
any money for it it's just something
that really you know once Allah gives
you knowledge about something like you
have to go teach it you know because you
know he didn't just give it to you for
yourself in your own family you have to
go out and tell the rest of the
community about it and so I'm happy to
tell him and alhamdulillah all praise
and thanks to Allah
many many many communities have invited
me to teach this program and it's a dark
subject you know I mean I have to admit
it it's it's it's a it's a hard thing to
realize what's going on but the first
step is just to realize the darkness
that's around you so you can turn the
light on
beautiful huh thank you thank you for
sharing that with us sure how many
people could be motivated to talk more
about it
inshaallah last month allah we can
implement these steps and we can take
the matter more serious so we can do
like allah the almighty told us to save
ourselves and our families from the
hellfire exactly so we know our enemy
and we can be better prepared that enemy
to mankind is the Shaitaan and the
satanic forces and this is one of those
tools that the dark forces they satanic
forces are using and s of this porn and
all those things that come with it
so we need to protect ourselves protect
our families and hope you benefit from
this we'll see you next time inshallah
God willing continue to tune in here to
the dean she'll subscribe if you haven't
already we'll see you next time
inshallah God willing until then peace
be with you assalamualaikum
this is the thing you know